earning play of the game during an  overwatch match feels good but if you  like to play as mercy you won't be  getting it as often now I'm Tony and  this is your nerfed GameSpot news update  the latest overwatch patch is live for  all versions of the game and as usual it  makes some balance changes the biggest  of these is for mercy's resurrection  ability simply put her ultimate won't  win play of the game is frequently now  additional tweaks include increased  speed to the payload on ice and Valda  some user interface changes and the  usual bug fixes overwatch is constantly  receiving fresh updates and content with  a new character reveal on the horizon so  mercy stats may change again in the  future what do you think of the change  let me know in the comments or on  twitter at chaingun Pope and for all the  biggest overwatch news you're already in  the right place